alan turing is someone who spent a lot
of time
thinking about the mystery of
consciousness
and what it means to be alive his work
in computing
also tackled these questions and with
his ideas about the turing machine and
the tiering test
he no doubt brushed up against the
questions of
whether a computer could be considered
to be alive or conscious
and where a classification would leave
the field of artificial
intelligence as a boy alan turing read a
book
called natural wonders by edwin tenny
brewster
and he later told his mum that it was
this book that opened his heart
and mind to science the book explores
lots of wonderful ideas around the
science of life
including questioning aliveness and a
chapter
on where we do our thinking while doing
research for this video i
enjoyed this book so much that i wanted
to read it out to you
and so i've started a podcast doing just
that
the first episode about how the chicken
gets inside the egg
is up now for everyone and the rest of
the episodes will be available
through my patreon for now though let's
have a look at the chapter
called how much of us is alive
the author talks about how much of a
tree
could be considered to be alive the bark
is dead
and the wood is dead between the two is
a
thin layer which is alive the green
leaves are alive
and the twigs but at least half of
every living tree is already dead
the blood we say is the life and yet
the blood itself is dead the watery part
is just soup water and salt and fat and
jelly
the minute coin-like red blood
corpuscles
carry the oxygen of the air from the
lungs all over the body
but there are similar oxygen carriers
likewise dead
in bottles in the drugstore maybe this
question of whether our blood is
considered alive or dead
could be better left to philosophers but
this is the view that the author holds
and he describes us as being made of
living bricks but set in a dead
mortar perhaps it is the incompleteness
of this explanation that inspired alan
turing
to want to explore how to get from
a series of living bricks to
intelligence
and turing did have a lifelong passion
for
biology i'll put on screen some pictures
from some of his less known work on the
topic of
morphogenesis and trying to understand
where the patterns and living things
whether it's
in the fur of animals and the patterns
and the colors
all the way down to the way the seeds
arrange themselves in a flower head
turing was trying to understand how this
could happen
from kind of a mathematical perspective
and these ideas are also particular
favorites of mine i've always been
really fascinated by this
interface of biology and maths and
finding patterns in nature so
i really love having a look at some of
this work
questioning the nature of aliveness
is also something that influenced the
way that
alan turing approached childhood grief
an important part of the story of alan
turing's life
is that of his childhood best friend and
possibly first love christopher morkham
alan and christopher would spend a lot
of time together at the
sherbourne school library where they
would discuss their ideas in mathematics
and science
christopher was a year older than ellen
and also a very gifted mathematician
he had won a scholarship to study at
cambridge university
but he died in 1930 at age 18
before he was ever able to take up his
place
he died from bovine tuberculosis which
came from drinking infected cow's milk
and the loss was really difficult for
touring
he stayed close with christopher's
mother and wrote her a letter
all about his thoughts on the spirit in
which he says that
the body provides something for the
spirit
to look after and use it sounds like
this was his way of
wrapping his head around the loss and
also comforting her
tearing also resolved to work extra hard
going forward
to make up for the great potential that
had been lost
christopher's mum created a science
prize at the school
to help remember christopher bai and the
very first winner of that prize
was alan turing and as part of his prize
he got to select a book the one he chose
was called
mathematical recreations and essays
the last chapter of this book was about
cryptographs and
ciphers and it was quite possibly the
first
place where turing encountered those
ideas
eight years later he would be working at
the british code breaking organization
and helping to develop solutions to
decrypting
enigma machine messages now some of
these solutions that he was helping to
develop
were first worked out by polish code
breakers
the chapter starts by giving some
definitions of a cryptograph and a
cipher
it says here that a cryptograph may be
defined as a manner of writing
in which the letters or symbols employed
are used in their normal sense
but are so arranged that the
communication is intelligible
only to those possessing the key a
simple example
is a communication in which every word
is spelt backwards
a cipher may be defined as a manner of
writing
by characters arbitrarily invented or by
an arbitrary
use of letters words or characters
in any other than their ordinary sense
intelligible only to those possessing
the key
a simple example is when each letter is
replaced by the one that
immediately follows it in the natural
order of the alphabet
a being replaced by b b by c
and so on finally z by a
in a communication cipher symbols may be
arranged cryptographically
and thus further hinder a reading of the
message
so the message above as a cryptographic
cipher
would be this quite confusing message
down here
but of course these messages get much
more complicated than these examples
later in the chapter the author goes on
to talk about cipher machines
he says that there's a risk of some
instrument
when set falling into unauthorized hands
and this must be taken into account
since equally good ciphers can be
constructed without the use of a
mechanical device
i do not think their employment can be
recommended
now after this was written cipher
machines
would go on to become the norm and alan
turing who read this book
would go on to attack the enigma machine
which
is an example of one so perhaps not
everything in this book is
totally up to date but both of these
books i've mentioned
so far are now in the public domain so
you can read them yourself for free
and there'll be links in the description
to do that
of course there are plenty of other
books and people
who inspired alan turing throughout his
life and
in his childhood and we can see another
resource here which is
the complete list of library books that
alan borrowed while he was a student at
the sherbourne school as mentioned in my
previous video
he read a lot of books about math
science
physics and astronomy and not so many
fiction books
and his english teacher tried to
encourage him to read more of those
he did read the alice in wonderland
books which did have a bit of a
mathematical bend to them
but i find looking at this list of books
that he read as a student
to be pretty interesting it would seem
to me that even when he was young
he knew what he was interested in and he
pursued those things he was interested
in
and eventually found success in them
thanks as always to my patreon
supporters
and a special shout out to today's
patreon cat of the day
cheeto thanks for watching and i hope to
see you next time